in this video I'm going to show you how
to do a garlic nasal rinse or a flush
and it's mainly for those people that
have a lot of congestion in their
sinuses chronically Through The Years so
you know you have seen seasonal
allergies but you also have people that
have always are always stuffy and that
has to do with a fungus in their sinosis
okay one of the best things to kill
funguses and viruses are is basically
garlic so I'm going to show to do a
garlic nasal rinse very very simply this
is what you're going to do um you're
going to take one garlic clove so it's
just going to be one of these little
sections and don't take the whole thing
okay and you're going to peel unpeel it
and you're going to chop it up into
small little pieces and then you're
going to wait for 15 minutes okay then
you're going to actually while you're
waiting for 15 minutes you're going to
boil um
a half a cup of of water let me just put
pour a half a cup of water you're going
to boil a half a cup of water and while
you're waiting for this 15 minutes okay
and then you're going to take the garlic
all chopped up and put it in a little
bit of a strainer right here so you're
going to put the garlic in there and
then you're going to maybe place it in a
cup like a coffee cup and pour the half
a glass of hot boiling water over this
garlic okay and it's going to have a
fluid that comes out into your cup
so we're going to wait until the
temperature of that boiling
water becomes lukewarm you maybe want to
put in the refrigerator for a while to
speed it up but do not flush your
sinuses with pure garlic with in the
water and boiling H that would be a
problem okay you would really have a
problem so don't do that so we want to
wait until it's lukewarm and then we're
going to actually use a nety pot or this
nasal rinse flush thing you can get
these I guess at CVS
or a netti pot but basically what you do
is soon as this this fluid becomes um
lukewarm you're going to pour it into
this plastic thing or a netti pot a nety
pot it looks like a little teapot it's
the same deal you're basically going to
when it becomes lukewarm you're going to
put this in your nose and kind of flush
it over the
sink and you can you know watch a video
on how that happens like because I'm not
going to demonstrate this but the
instructions are there it's not hard to
do you're just going to gently just push
the water and squeeze this or pour it as
the water comes on the other nostril and
all this garlic will go up into your
sinuses and start to break down the
fungus mold mildew viruses whatever is
in their bacteria and you'll see that
you'll start to blow a lot of stuff out
and it'll actually be clear so it helps
the mucus membranes it's amazing so I
would do that actually
daily or every other day for a couple
weeks if it's really bad and watch how
the silenes clear up it's a great
natural remedy uh it's very good for
funguses and just make sure that you do
not put hot water too hot make sure it's
lukewarm and make sure that you do not
have actual garlic chunks in the mixture
okay so go ahead and try this and let me
know how it
works